hey guys it's dense the fatter thick
hair and I'm David Griffin your resident
comic book and video game guru and this
is our review of the amazing spider-man
2 directed by marc webb very i didn't
think it was gonna be the kind of
controversial movie not controversial in
this is the subject matter but in terms
of it's been very divisive amongst the
fan base see those critics are split in
the way yeah there's like people that
love it there's people that hate it I
personally come in kind of in between
where I enjoyed myself but there's
definitely some major issues with it so
we'll probably talk about our general
thoughts and then we'll go into some
spoilers later what are your overall
thoughts about it overall thoughts is I
was a little disappointed by this movie
anyway I say disappointed ease up they
don't don't know it firing back at me uh
I would say go see in the theater I
think it's worth seen but it's just
that's such great character moments
there's some awesome moments between
Peter and it may great chemistry between
Andrew Garfield in am emma stone awesome
chemistry but the villains I mean they
just weren't developed great actors
mm-hmm kid from Chronicle always forget
his name ahan inna hot one of my
favorite upcoming great actor looks like
young Leonardo DiCaprio good actor Jamie
Foxx connect but I felt like the
villains almost like spider-man 3 not as
bad not nearly as bad not as many early
as bad as spider-man 3 but there's kind
of like thrown at you it's like here's a
lecture oh here's you know this it's
just like I wanted some more development
I thought they just I feel like it's
kind of rushed even though lose two
hours and 20 minutes it felt rushed
which was I don't know yeah it was it's
weird it was to rush but was too long at
the same exactly yeah like there were
times where I kind of was bored yeah I'm
like oh can we just hurry up with this
but the same time they were rushing
through some stuff with their characters
will talk about in the spoiler section
it like they just show them and then we
don't really care in yeah it's just
overall they're just they were just
trying to do too much they're trying to
set up this sinister six sequel like
spider-man 3 a big sister 6 thing they
want to do like a venom movie they want
to do is Sinister Six movie and this was
and you know I had done a review for aim
suture and
one of the guys from AMC Kristian
harloff from uh schmoes know he said
something about it and it kind of like I
was like oh yeah right that's the thing
that I felt about it was the same reason
same feeling I got from Iron Man 2 okay
where I didn't think it was a bad movie
right but I was disappointed yeah and
the some of the same things that that
had issues with with iron man 2 I had
with spider-man 2 where they were trying
to shoehorn all this stuff in there I
wanted to ask you about that I don't
know if you feel the same way but I
could feel the franchise building this
movie it felt like they were building a
French granted that sounds maybe unfair
because every Marvel movie that comes
out is building upon the franchise but
for some reason throw the dark world
captain america the winter soldier even
though they're building a French as it
felt self-contained when I was watch
this I'm like man they are really trying
to build this universe for them to make
all these kind of movies and I could
feel it I didn't like feeling that I
guess it just kind of left me unsettled
unsatisfied I didn't feel like I got a
complete movie at the end well also with
the Marvel it's more natural when they
enter great stuff than that it's part of
the universe it just feels much more
natural right in in this movie it felt
like okay we got to make sure that you
see this character you need to see this
you need to see this but we're not going
to develop it at all I mean okay so
positive stuff yes the Gwen Stacy Peter
Park recapture great chemistry and way
better than you know something like the
the tobey maguire curse curse does
Indian the Sam Raimi's spider-man like
that was so flat tonight so I was
invested in their relationship I thought
I feel Sally Field was great and may you
know Peter Parker I think andrew
garfield is a great Peter Parker you
know yeah um some of the stuff with
spider-man though I'm not a hundred
percent behind some of the jokes that
you know we're childlike childish you
know there are too many stuff but I
think as Peter Parker is great dane
dehaan is Harry Osborn I think was
really good I wanted he needed more he
needed more time especially his
transition to Green Goblin which right
and they there's not a spoiler we all
know he right shes photos okay we got
her too fast too fast
didn't buy it you know they should have
held off to the next movie or something
like that right you know I saw it you
know spider-man with we know with Mike
here from think here as well and you
know he was commenting that you know you
didn't there's no time for their
friendship to develop he comes back from
being gone I don't know eight to ten
years whatever and he's just kind of
there they have a little talk by the
water and then things just start going
like I wish they would have spent at
least in the Sam Raimi version I believe
we got a full movie with James Franco's
as Harry Osborn before he went bad so I
feel like I wish that guy had at least
one full movie as a post just like
couldn't when you see him it's just like
it's too rushed everything's just to
rush this would be but it's also too
long it's weird saying that it's just
it's really is them mm-hmm I mean I
enjoyed the action I have something Oh
effects are really stable flying through
the city in the beginning I mean it
looks great like you know she didn't 3d
and all that like it looks so good all
the him swing in and the the had his his
webbing the bladder like Todd
McFarlane's mm-hmm you know the whole
like Webb's the whole design that he
used to do it all the bigger eyes to
your eyes yes on the costume as well it
look great yeah and then you know the
battle scenes with electro hula brewing
yeah Green Goblin and all that stuff and
you know with with rhino like doesn't
like I pokemon i don't know he like the
suit is cool but the character is just
it's too over them accent is over the
top Russian accent or whatever he's
trying to I just didn't even even
Electro's I didn't I didn't like the max
Dillon part when he would when he before
he turns so like try to comical for me
yeah like to again too fast he's like
kinda you feel bad for him it's kind of
a nice guy he likes spiderman he seems
like he just everybody just stepping
over them they just goes like full dark
evil guy at the end like it's just too
fast everything was just too rushed okay
so you know let's give our overall
impressions Igraine let's get into some
spoilers um so overall yes I liked it
but there were problems with it I've
seen it twice already and I do know the
second time I watched it I felt more
bored with it interesting because you
know the stuff that that okay the stuff
that i liked i still liked it but there
was the stuff
I didn't like and some of the filler
stuff I was just like really bored with
and so okay I feel like it's a missed
opportunity you had a lot of potential a
lot of cool stuff but I feel like they
were more worried about setting up
sinister six than they were about
telling a good story luckily for me I'm
invested in the Peter Parker Gwen Stacy
relationship I thought that worked
really well you know Andrew Garfield as
Peter Parker work it's just a lot of
this other stuff that they try to
shoehorn in so uh action was very
entertaining and so you know i i'm not
saying like this is something you have
to go see right if you're a fan of
spider-man you should see just because
you will be entertaining in some parts
of it but you may get upset I mean
there's people that I know that just
absolutely hate this movie yeah
interesting and then there's people who
love it but they just you know don't see
any flaws with it and I'm kind of just
more of a mixed bag I'm gonna give it a
C+ Wow yeah I thought maybe a b-minus
but yeah on the second viewing it i
think i have to give it a c-plus who as
you i I've only seen it once and when I
first got out I immediately thought it's
like okay we're gonna review is for
think here at some point what am I gonna
give it and at first I was thinking
excels little under a while mistake
maybe Abby it was solid entertaining
woke up the next morning I don't make it
sound so dramatic i woke up I was like
oh oh you know like wasn't that dramatic
but I thought the more I got away from
it the I just feel as good about can I
got this feeling in my stomach and I
like you know what I think that for me
this is gonna be a b-minus okay um see
flashy cheapest doesn't really surprise
me but I just I wanted to love it I did
enjoy I liked I would like to see the
second time to see if I can share those
same opinions as you do but just yeah I
think it was a missed opportunity think
they rushed too many things in the
spoiler section after this talk about
the end credits even did this story like
Campea describe john k we describe to me
what the end credit situation was even
that was weird like why that got thrown
in there it's just there's a lot of
stuff that just didn't it felt rushed
and just underdeveloped but great
performances great chemistry between
emma stone andrew garfield is Peter
Parker and Gwen Stacy and I want to see
more
garfa the spider man I do you enjoy him
but again you know just kind of
underwhelmed yeah okay all right so now
we're going to spoiler section so if you
haven't seen the verb the movie a we're
gonna talk about everything that
happened there so I'll go with the
positives I thought I thought that you
know besides we've been talking about
Peter Parker Gwen Stacy like I thought
that the way they handled her death was
great like III you know a great scene
yeah and I we knew I didn't happen but I
didn't know even when she was falling I
was like maybe it'll keep her alive
maybe they will maybe they'll be like a
BAM to the fans like oh you thought but
you know we're gonna do it next move
exactly that's what i was thinking yeah
but I you know it was like I remember
everyone the fear was a call oh yeah I
mean like the webbing like it's like a
hand turned a way to reach a little
dramatic kind of cheesy little cheesy
but I liked it and then even when she
hit like you don't it's fast you don't
really see her head hit you think like
maybe she survived even like goes a
second her eyes I think kind of opened I
was like ah it's more the sounding hair
snake a snap and it's a so I actually
thought that was well done those good
yeah we talked about the whole Aunt May
and Peter Parker scene of when you
probably asked about her his father
right here and she's like you're my boy
your Baba like her before that was so
great really good performance that was
another thing though the kind of
shoehorned also the story of Peter
Parker's parents also on top of you know
the Green Goblin origin the electro
orange didn't care about his performance
like his dad's middle message I mean it
was nice moment to hear him say like I
love my son and we didn't abandon you we
didn't leave you like that was nice but
it just didn't didn't do much for me
didn't do much and let's talk about the
Ryanair sequence completely unnecessary
in my opinion we didn't need it in the
beginning with before he gets in the
Rhino soup I would cool yeah the shade
Russian accent well you always a great
oh yeah dude can act it's like seeing
him just be silly like that it's just
too ridiculous and then at the end he
comes back right right now said Rhino
suit looks awesome but the scene to me
was just too cheesy and man
and I yeah and then I mean let's go into
let's talk about the next about Harry
Osborn again great great great actor but
again just felt rushed you know comes
back been away diagnosed he realizes he
has the same disease as his dad and he's
gonna die so then he just rushes really
fast and he gets bad you mean we see
just like James Franco drink a lot of
scotch you know all that kind of stuff
you know and then in his transformation
like I like the way he looked like his
teeth and his like kind of face was kind
of greenish like I like the way look but
seeing him just laughing it's just too
fast it was way too fast this should
have been next the next film I don't
want to see it this one she's a you
remind me of kind of like how they had
added to face at the end of dark night I
love the dark knight right but we didn't
need to see the whole all the two-faced
stuff at the end right have save that
for another movie they just kind of and
that's what the Green Goblin was because
so I like the relationship between Peter
and Harry and that chemistry and so I
thought that went well but then the turn
yeah for him to become green goblin was
just next moment we see in like haha
yeah it was like it was out of place he
shows up after electro he just fought
electro then Green Goblin sounds on the
item too much and it wasn't again we're
not saying this is like you know Sam
Raimi's spider-man 3 and for some of you
like them but I thought that was awful
but this because the chemistry between
everybody was so good but again it felt
like they just forcing too many bad guys
and I think I leaned over i was watching
it you know it's with mike i leaned over
i was like we don't even seen rhino yet
mmm it was like after the big fight
seagulls like where's Ryan then they
just show him at the end which is the
scene you see in the trailers of him you
know blocking the two missiles with the
sewer grate very much you've seen it you
see it just cuts two credits and then I
was like okay and then I mean we'll go
back some other stuff but then at the
end what frustrated me is then we see
this you know you and I are both looking
for Disney x-men days of future past but
seeing that Cena Jennifer Lawrence
kicking butt like in the mid credit
scene all the big credit scenes in
Marvel's grand this is Sony are linked
to the bigger universe at least to some
degree or at least maybe an afterthought
of what happened after the movie was
over with but this was I guess it
according to you know John Campea
informed me is that the director was had
to deal with Fox and Sony wanted him to
do this so I said okay if he does this
movie
we got to be able to put a little ad
freshman days we dress but if you don't
know what's coming you assume that could
be a sequel because all it shows is the
X symbol and then the scene then it's
done like you might not know that's exim
days of future past if you're not a fan
of the you know the French yes so that
was or you'll think that x-men and
spider-man are linked it's like oh they
gonna have a mash-up like there for
Lauren's gonna be in the next movie I
mean it's just I just thought everything
was kind of thrown together that's why
they go with something that was
disappointed in that I want to see a
better ends stupid a judge movie on its
end credits it's kind of dumb but I want
to see something different I I like to
see after Gwen Stacy's death I like like
them showing Peter visiting the grave
the passage of time and I did like him
listening to the graduation speech about
time it kind of comes together yeah that
heart is nice and then I do agree or he
should come back as spider-man to be
like the end thing they just didn't need
to do the whole Rhino thing it literally
could have been like him saving up some
people from a mugger right women yeah I
was that I've been on it something small
just that we know that spider-man is
back right yeah that's all I really
needed they didn't need to do the Rhino
thing but again that's why I know you
think you agree to is what we felt you
feel the franchise building more than in
Marvel the Marvel Studios films it's
kind of nice weave it in nice and
intricately this felt you just feel it
like it's trying to force something out
and be like hey this is what we're doing
next and I mean I I'm looking I want you
to the Sinister Six movie I just hope
they do more with rhino and more Paul
Giamatti like give him something good if
it's gonna be slapstick comedy then do
that but at least make it better well
that's the thing is this movie tonally
and structurally is kind of all over the
place you know at some moment it feels
very kiddush and childlike and you know
spider is making cracking corny jokes
and blah blah blah england's as he dies
then quasar yeah snapped her neck and al
are that's so it just kind of goes all
over the place in terms of tone and just
story-wise like okay what's going on
here it's weird like this is it I don't
know if this we're talk about this movie
cuz i dont i dont really dislike it just
i thought i was just disappointing I
expected more from this franchise even
though i did enjoy myself while I was
watching the movie I had a good time
theater you know parts of it and you
know enough for were like okay generally
liked it but it had so many issues that
I don't you know upon seeking the second
time was like oh can we just go past
this point right yeah can we
fast-forward through this and you know I
don't think I'm gonna see it again at
least not for a long long time yeah the
first one was definitely better yeah you
knew what it was I think it was you know
people complain that it was too dark it
was too emo it was but it knew what it
was other than that she's a crane scene
I was good with it you know where this
one was like it was kind of had those
those cheesy crane seen tight moments
and then they have something serious
then they have a cheesy and then then
they have you know let's talk about
Peters parents and then look at you know
all that suck when stacy is going to
Europe she's going to London and then
you know like just and what do you think
of max Dillon like as before he turns to
lecture because I thought he was cool
when he was electro but before I
actually liked him as my belly I really
like this guy like Jimmy Fox because the
engine foxes you know in Django
Unchained he's Jamie Foxx he's cool you
know blame it on and all that stuff all
the music but I mean he's I like him
being goofy and silly i like seeing
Jamie Foxx like that I just wish we
could have seen that longer again I
thought the villains are just rushed
there's just too much too fast but I
mean hopefully you know maybe spider-man
3 will be better you know this is all
before we go I want to just be predict
something if I may there was a seamless
trailer that I'm sure will seen deleted
scenes on the blu-ray or whatever that
was cut out where Norman Osborn is at
his desk with all you know guess all the
files open and he shows like hey you
know Oscorp has been following you and
they flipped through these photos
there's one foot of a little kid you
know who looks like me well he has a
little mini after was much younger but
and it looks like you know the whole
linkage or the whole thing with like
Miles Morales Brian Michael Bendis his
story of this young I say half
african-american half Hispanic character
and garfield has been interviewed
recently and he said that he would mind
passing the torch to Miles Morales let's
say Garfield does one more movie hurry
so I wonder if we're even going to see
Peter Parker I don't think they've made
me kill them but go away go away for a
while and then maybe Miles Morales would
feel then maybe they'd recast spider-man
later
some interesting things to think about
in the future oh speaking of like other
stuff in the trailer you know we had
seen that sequence where we see a
shadowy figure right walk across it at
Oscorp and we see doc aux armes we see
vulture we're swings you know we see the
movie that's it yeah there's nothing
more to that than what we saw from the
trailer right you know the only thing we
we find out is like that guy's mr.
fierce yeah we're whoever that is you
know and and that that Norman is still
alive and obviously he's probably gonna
be the one that puts all the Sinister
Six it together for the next movie but
not really much there yeah I think there
was a thing I left the theater thinking
like that didn't get me excited for this
even though I want to see the next one
when it comes out it didn't get me then
it didn't it didn't get me excited about
it yeah I'm already thinking about
gardens the galaxy and Godzilla coming
out to know alright guys so that's what
we thought of the amazing spider-man 2
let us know what you think cuz i know
there's gonna be tons of opinions are
gonna be able to be heated I love it I
hate it it was terrible it was awesome
it was ok is ok oh you can post your
comments on our website pinky or calm or
on our YouTube channel think you're Pro
make sure to subscribe that you also
come find us on Twitter we're all at
think hero hear me dennis michael and if
you want to talk to us about what you
thought about the movie if you disagree
this movie was awesome and let us know
why you know we'd love to hear your
opinions lets you know of course I think
hero i'm at griffin de waste of a
Facebook page that's facebook.com slash
think carroll fans and make sure you
like that page and share our videos on
twitter and facebook all that stuff
you